Luke Tom Nate Jacob and a bunch of other
kids here with the outdoor boys YouTube
channel today we're catching big carp
and camping and cooking and having a
ball is that right
[Applause]
me Bekka the three boys we're going
camping and since I'm bringing my wife
this will not be a survival video we're
also meeting two other couples there who
are gonna be bringing their small kids
as well and so it's gonna be a real fun
activity we're gonna be doing some
fishing and other things and I'm in
charge of the food and as you can see I
am taking my responsibilities very
seriously and remember folks glamping
starts in the kitchen so I'm gonna get
some preparations done
[Music]
there goes Scotch egg one down loving to
go alright we got the food prepared got
the gear set out need to load the car
get to bed I have a case this morning in
a courthouse very close to where we're
going camping so the game plan is that
as soon as I get done with work I'm
gonna go and set up the camp's I get
everything going and then when once the
kids get out of school Becca's gonna
grab them and meet us up there well this
seems like as good a place as any to
change my wardrobe here
got plenty of room to set up tents big
old fire pit over there and we got the
river right there I have got to get
everything comfy and ready for my wife
brand-new ten man easy up tent okay I
bought this tent along with the others
with the hopes of one day doing a tent
review video and I guess I extend this
till that clicks well that was
remarkably straightforward didn't read
the instructions and it pops up at about
three or four minutes so we'll see how
it is getting it back in the bag though
that'll be the real challenge
you know you prick Christian is
interesting we got some other friends
coming along Becca
and the boys should be here any minute
so I've got a hustle get the tent up and
I gotta get some food going cuz when
they arrive I want it to be perfect
I do a good job Becca might come camping
with me again yeah go show your mom
alright we got the fire going to make
some coals for cooking and while that's
happening I'm gonna make some carp bait
cuz that River is supposed to have some
carp in it and I want to catch them yeah
can I add some corn
all right got my strawberry jell-o panco
corn packed bait here and while the fire
is maturing I'm gonna go and throw a
couple balls of this stuff out see if we
can't chum some carp up so we're going
full americano here mark here's brought
firepower
[Music]
[Music]
there we go put that one in the video
that's a black cloud
thank you I haven't shot I haven't shot
a gun in forever I gotta get started on
the cooking I promised Becca there'd be
food here for when she arrived and
tonight we're doing a Japanese kielbasa
curry so making these Japanese curries
super easy it's the same way you make
any sort of stew whatever start off with
the stuff that takes the longest to cook
like potatoes and then you just work
your way up
so go potatoes carrots onions beans you
know mushrooms that sort of thing you
can use any meat you want and curry but
I think chopped up kielbasa is the
absolute best for Japanese curry just
breezy and flavorful
all right now we got all the veggies
cooked we add the curry some fish in
here some carp all right got a ball by
panco bait here and I've got my spot
Chum doubt out there and we're gonna put
the two together and see if we can't
catch a fish all right we got the bile
arm set up nice and loud so I'm gonna go
relax a little bit and see if see if we
pick anything up
[Music]
got a fish here hold on hold on your
dregs oh oh it's a big one that didn't
take long
there we go there we go congratulations
is this your biggest fish you've ever
caught yeah I think he's probably just
shy under 20 pounds come here put your
hands underneath them
now put them in the water alright guys
there we go we landed one carp I think
we're gonna have a couple more I'm gonna
throw some more Chum on the spot keep
the fish interested and let's go get
another one
well my charming wife is always good
luck when fishing she shows up and
immediately the carp start biting Oh
should probably read the instructions to
add rice stir cover and remove from heat
all right all right that's it
all right tighten that drag tighten that
drag hold on hold on hold on hold on
yeah let's put that or did that bust off
definitely no fish on now huh no no fish
yard he popped the line okay the bad
news is the car got away the good news
is I think the rice might be done and
we're ready for dinner so all right it
is dinner time let's get some curry
going check out tommy's meat trident
oh you drop it course because it's a
bullet mark here is making some food and
I get to sit down on my butt and I'm
loving that we split the strawberry and
the Apple down the middle and this is
just a yellow cake mix so we're gonna
pour that over the top and then you take
8 ounces of 7up or sprite or whatever
you have oh just let the soda do the
doggy and then we're gonna throw some
butter on there just for good measure
oh my goodness look at that beauty look
at that cobbler okay who's got the line
here the camera there we go buddy
want to put my Nathan's hair all-right
basin what you got
go ahead oh you got a serious fish there
keep that rod tip up up in the air up in
the air what happened what happened your
fish did you break the line holy crap
this one's bigger he's over 20 27 pounds
that you biggest common carp isn't it
good alright guys it's late we've had a
ball but I am going to bed and I will
see you guys in the morning
hey Jacob you having fun
you want to go catch a fish yeah cooked
apples alright we're getting a little
surprise rainstorm it's coming in here
[Music]
13 foot grizzly bear just the pad on his
paw would be about that wide all right
here here in fishing Bell's of going
seek something about dragged this rod up
here he's got a fish on yeah I think he
just popped off there another cart broke
us off so what I'm figuring out is
there's a lot of these sharp rocks in
here and braided line is not very good
with the brazen resistance if I had to
do it over again I'd bring mono and I
don't think we'd lose half as many fish
if we're using mono line Jacob you
having fun yeah it's like 65 degrees and
the boys are swimming hypothermia is fun
kids Christian's got something looks
like a decent bass honestly well I'm
gonna go down here just a little ways
and try sight casting for carp just a
little bit I'm just gonna get my boots
wet
there's a pot of four or five big carp
under this tree here I'm just sitting
with the rod in my hand
precision casting in the rain gods are
we've pricked most of the fish in that
pod and they're kind of on to us because
they're not taking our bait swimming
right over it ever made it's dead over
here indeed Jacob are you touching those
with your hands yeah don't do that buddy
oh that's great hey Nathan are you in
your pajamas you're in your PJs the
secret formula for having a good campout
fishing adventure with my boys is fine
someplace that you can throw them in the
water and they can get muddy they can
get muddy they'll be happy that's mine
that's mine there we go they're not too
shabby this creeks full of surprises so
somebody was unhappy when I would often
caught a fish without him we're gonna
have a little Jacob back guess what's
coming
there you go buddy is that better I
really like this coleman 10 man 10 it's
pretty good I'll be doing a review about
it later but yeah I wouldn't use it in
high wind but other than that it's
pretty nice do you like camping
[Music]
what is the cow say guys did you have
fun well listen if you want to see more
great videos from the outdoor boy's
youtube channel don't forget to we put
out new videos every Saturday morning
thanks for watching if you like this
video don't forget to check out the
outdoor boys youtube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that Bell
button
education thanks for watching